newse voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track where your news
is coming from news voice helps you
track what corporate interests might be
influencing the narratives in the news
you read every day arm yourself against
corporate media monopolies by
downloading the news voice app for free
using the link right underneath this
video we're going to start today talking
about John Bolton and there is so much
to say and so many different angles to
this story so let's get right into it
one of Donald Trump's former national
security advisors because he's had many
it's very close to releasing a book the
book is scheduled to be released on
Tuesday June 23rd we have a bunch of the
claims that are in the book to tell you
about momentarily but the first part of
this is about Donald Trump and the
Justice Department under Donald Trump's
AG William bar working really hard to
suppress the release of the book the I
the story needs a disclaimer now I want
to be I'm gonna keep saying this today
because it's important because it's been
a few months since we last talked about
John Bolton's book John Bolton is
absolutely horrible John Bolton is of
the worst of the worst when it comes to
his political worldview he's one of the
key architects of the 2003 Iraq war
which doesn't seem he regrets being a
part of to this day he's a horrible
neoconservative he's not someone that
progressives would ever consider an ally
on policy and someone whose entire moral
compass is fundamentally broken so I the
reason I want to do this is there's
already some supposedly lists out there
talking about liberals are falling for
both they're falling all over themselves
to praise Bolton bad people sometimes
tell the truth in other words bad people
aren't always lying John Bolton seems to
be a fierce advocate for what he
believes is right and true and he
doesn't tend to get pushed around I
almost always disagree with him about
what is right in this particular case
Bolton has decided that it is correct
and profitable and this is important
to get into that to tell the story as he
sees it of what happened when he was
Donald Trump's national security adviser
this is not praise of John Bolton and
I'm gonna go back to that
so the Trump administration has been
panicking and they have sued Bolton to
try to prevent the release of the book
Trump's Justice Department is trying to
suppress the book remember this they
said this would be the most transparent
administration ever the most for free
speech administration ever they're going
through any number of different
arguments trying anything they can to
see what sticks
including claiming that the publication
of Bolton's book risks compromising
national security now there is something
funny in that there is some truth in the
national security concerns around
Bolton's book but what I mean by that is
what Bolton alleges in the book which I
will get to is so damning to Donald
Trump that it exposes the United States
to being taken advantage of by showing
how incompetent and clueless Donald
Trump is it actually might encourage our
adversaries to try to take advantage of
the United States
knowing how incompetent Donald Trump is
according to the book but from a legal
perspective these arguments are all very
tired they're likely not going to work
partially thanks to the First Amendment
to the Constitution of the United States
now in the lawsuit against Bolton
there's a few different arguments the
lawsuit says Bolton violated the
contract he signed when he became
national security advisor by writing the
book they make another argument in the
lawsuit that says Bolton has not allowed
enough time for the book to be vetted to
see if it contains government secrets
Donald Trump the other day said he
thinks if the book gets published Bolton
will have criminal problems but before
we get into that here is Trump saying
any conversation with him is de facto
classified which is another argument
he's making about why Bolton's book
shouldn't be published and somebody said
he went out and wrote a book if he wrote
a book I can't imagine that he can
because that's highly classified
information even conversations with me
they're highly classified I told that to
the
in general before I will consider every
conversation with me as president highly
classified now that isn't true
presidents can choose to classify or
declassify whatever they want but there
is no legal basis to say retro actively
every conversation that I had with
Bolton is classified that's an insanely
broad legal claim courts are very
unlikely to accept such a claim let's
keep going though here's more of what
Trump said about Bolton being a criminal
so that would mean that if he wrote a
book and if the book gets out he's
broken the law and I would think that he
would have criminal problems I hope so
otherwise I mean they put a sailor in
jail because he sent a photograph of his
bed and an engine of an old submarine
and if this guy's writing writing things
about conversations or about anything
and maybe he's not telling the truth
he's been known not to tell the truth a
lot so legal experts believe that Bolton
would not have legal problems but his
publisher would also potentially be
liable there and the publisher has
obviously done a huge legal review
before the book is going to print the
First Amendment is quite strong here as
well now there is a footnote in the
lawsuit against Bolton where the
Department of Justice is asking a court
to ban every bookstore in the United
States from selling the book that is
critical of President Trump what would
we be saying if in any other country we
saw a court being asked by a president
to ban book stores from selling a book
that's critical of the president just
think about that and when we see all of
these supposedly enlightened hot takes
from some on the Left saying oh it's
liberals falling for it again now
believing Bolton who in 2003 was the bad
guy what would we be saying if a
different country was trying to use the
courts to prevent book stores from
publishing a book now the reality in
terms of the vetting is that the
manuscript was first sent to the White
House's National Security Council in
December that's six seven months ago at
this point and ultimately this is not
about classified information this is
not about state secrets this is not
really about national security this is
about a book whose claims and content is
very embarrassing to Donald Trump that's
really what this is about now I have to
tell you
Trump's concern may be overblown to a
degree because yes now that we found out
what's in the book which I'll tell you
in a moment a lot of media coverage of
it but most trumpets aren't going to buy
and read a book with several hundred
pages that's not what Trump is to do
most trumpets are going to see what Fox
News and Breitbart and Oh a n and you
know Mark Levin say about the book and
that will be what they believe so I
think some of the concern may be
overblown but what we've learned so far
is that Donald Trump is focused solely
on re-election and to the extent that he
believes the book may hurt his
re-election he's going to do everything
he can to suppress the book now we're
going to talk more about skepticism in a
moment we should apply skepticism here
to John Bolton as we always should when
there is a book because John Bolton is
going to make money from this book if
John Bolton's only priority was to get
the truth out he could have been doing
interview seven months ago and telling
us what's in the book I'm going to argue
later on in the show that John Bolton is
actually a traitor to the United States
for waiting seven months to tell us
about such damning allegations against
Donald Trump so there's no doubt that
there's a financial calculation here for
John Bolton that doesn't tell us whether
the claims in the book are true or false
and we have to see if the claims pass
the sniff test and they do we have to
see if the claims are similar to those
that have been made by others who have
spent time around around Donald Trump
and they are so is John Bolton
hypocritical in the sense that he didn't
testify for the House impeachment trial
and now he's publishing a book to make
money with absolutely bombshell claims
when he could have told us about these
seven months ago absolutely and I'm
gonna slam him for it in about 15
minutes but that doesn't mean that the
claims are untrue and that is what we
are going to be talking about again I
don't know that this is really going to
change Trump standing with trumpets who
aren't really gonna read the book they
don't really read but every little bit
anything that can help us remove Donald
Trump in November is something that we
should be looking at very very very
seriously and that's exactly what we're
going to do next